- Hello!
(audience applauding)
- Welcome to "The Kelly
Clarkson Show" and happy 2023!
(audience applauding)
I am your guest host for
the day, Niecy Nash Betts.
(audience applauding)
Kelly usually starts y'all
off with some singing
and although I am married
to a very talented singer,
Jessica Betts, apparently
that vocal talent
did not transfer with the last name.
(audience laughing)
But if we are lucky,
Jessica might have a
little something special
for us at the end of the show.
So please stick around.
(audience applauding)
Anyway, although Kelly's not here,
that doesn't mean you have
to go without her music.
Uh-uh, let's get things going
with the Kellyoke encore.
This is Kelly and her band,
Y'all with "Good As Hell"
by Lizo.
(audience applauding)
♪ I do my hair toss, check my nails ♪
♪ Baby how you feeling? ♪
♪ Feeling good as hell ♪
♪ Hair toss, check my nails ♪
♪ Baby how you feeling? ♪
♪ Feeling good as hell ♪
♪ Woo child, tired of
the (fingers snapping) ♪
♪ Go on dust your shoulders
off, keep it moving ♪
♪ Yes, Lord, tryna get some
new (fingers snapping) ♪
♪ In there, swimwear,
going-to-the-pool (fingers snapping) ♪
♪ Come now, come dry your eyes ♪
♪ You know you a star,
you can touch the sky ♪
♪ I know that it's hard
but you have to try ♪
♪ If you need advice, let me simplify ♪
♪ If he don't love you anymore ♪
♪ Just walk your fine ass out the door ♪
♪ I do my hair toss, check my nails ♪
♪ Baby how you feeling? ♪
♪ Feeling good as hell ♪
♪ Hair toss, check my nails ♪
♪ Baby how you feeling? ♪
♪ Feeling good as hell ♪
♪ Oh yeah ♪
♪ Baby how you feeling? ♪
♪ Feeling good as hell ♪
♪ Woo girl, need to kick off your shoes ♪
♪ Got to take a deep breath,
time to focus on you ♪
♪ All the big fights, long
nights that you been through ♪
♪ I got a bottle of tequila
I been saving for you ♪
♪ Boss up and change your life ♪
♪ You can have it all, no sacrifice ♪
♪ I know he did you wrong,
we can make it right ♪
♪ So go and let it all hang out tonight ♪
♪ 'Cause he don't love you anymore ♪
♪ Just walk your fine ass out the door ♪
♪ I do my hair toss, check my nails ♪
♪ Baby how you feeling? ♪
♪ Feeling good as hell ♪
♪ Hair toss, check my nails ♪
♪ Baby how you feeling? ♪
♪ Feeling good as hell ♪
♪ Oh yeah ♪
♪ Baby how you feeling? ♪
♪ Feeling good as hell ♪
(audience applauding)
Let's hear it one more time
for Kelly and her band Y'all.
(audience applauding)
That's right.
Okay, Y'all don't worry,
the next time I walk out
I want to hear y'all
playing "Brick House."
- Oh, okay.
- We got you.
- You got it.
- All day.
- All right, that is the way
you start off the new year,
good as hell.
(audience applauding)
That's right.